su sangre nómada corre por nuestras venas.
Pero al mismo tiempo,
distraídos por nuestro pan y circo
y envueltos en las guerras que hemos librado entre nosotros,
parece que hemos olvidado este deseo de explorar.
Como especie, hemos evolucionado de una forma única
para la Tierra, en la Tierra, y con la Tierra,
y contentos con nuestras condiciones de vida
nos hemos vuelto complacientes y estamos demasiado ocupados
para darnos cuenta de que sus recursos son finitos,
y que la vida de nuestro sol es también limitada.
Mientras que Marte y todas las películas creadas acerca de él
han reforzado la ética del viaje espacial,
pocos de nosotros parecemos darnos cuenta
de que la frágil constitución de nuestra especie
está muy mal preparada para los largos viajes espaciales.
Emprendamos una caminata por el bosque más cercano
y analicemos cuidadosamente la realidad.
Levanten rápidamente la mano:
¿Cuántos de Uds. piensan que podrían sobrevivir en esta naturaleza exuberante
unos días?
Bueno, bastantes.
¿Qué tal un par de semanas?
Un buen número.
¿Qué tal un par de meses?
Bastante bien también.
Ahora, imaginemos que este bosque
pasa por un invierno eterno.
La misma pregunta: ¿Cuántos de Uds. piensan que podrían sobrevivir unos días?
Unos cuantos.
¿Qué tal un par de semanas?
Ahora un toque divertido: imaginemos que la única fuente de agua disponible
está atrapada en bloques congelados a kilómetros debajo de la superficie.
La cantidad de nutrientes en el suelo es tan reducida
que no se encuentra en la vegetación,
y, por supuesto, casi no hay atmósfera.
Estos ejemplos son solo unos pocos de los muchos retos que enfrentaríamos
en un planeta como Marte.
¿Cómo podemos prepararnos para viajes a destinos mucho más remotos
que unas vacaciones al trópico?
¿Enviaremos suministros de forma continua desde la Tierra,
construiremos ascensores espaciales o kilómetros de cintas transportadoras
que conecten ese nuevo planeta a nuestro planeta natal?
¿Y cómo cultivaremos alimentos que crecen en la Tierra, como nosotros?
Pero me estoy adelantando.
En el viaje de nuestra especie
para encontrar un nuevo hogar bajo un nuevo sol,
es muy probable que invirtamos mucho tiempo en el viaje en sí,
en el espacio,
en una nave, una lata hermética voladora
probablemente por muchas generaciones.
El ser humano ha pasado tiempo de forma continuada en el espacio
un máximo de 12 a 14 meses.
A partir de las experiencias espaciales de los astronautas
sabemos que pasar tiempo en un ambiente de microgravedad
lleva a pérdida ósea, atrofia muscular, y problemas cardiovasculares
entre muchas otras complicaciones
de índole fisiológico y psicológico.
Para no hablar de la macrogravedad
o cualquier otra variación de la fuerza gravitacional
ejercida por el planeta en el que nos encontramos.
En resumen, nuestros viajes cósmicos estarán plagados de peligros
tanto conocidos como desconocidos.
Hasta ahora hemos estado buscando a esta nueva tecnología mecánica
o a esa próxima generación de robots
que puedan asegurarnos, como especie, un viaje seguro por el espacio.
Por maravillosos que sean, creo que ha llegado el momento
de complementar a estos gigantes electrónicos voluminosos
con algo que la naturaleza ya ha inventado:
el microbio, un organismo unicelular,
una máquina viva, capaz de auto-regenerarse y auto-mantenerse,
que necesita bastante poco para mantenerse,
ofrece mucha flexibilidad en el diseño
y solo hace falta transportarlo en un solo tubo de plástico.
El campo que nos ha permitido usar el potencial del microbio
se conoce como la biología sintética.
Proviene de la biología molecular, que nos ha dado antibióticos, vacunas,
y las mejores pautas para la observación
de los matices fisiológicos del cuerpo humano.
Con la ayuda de las herramientas de la biología sintética,
podemos editar los genes de casi cualquier organismo,
microscópico o no,
a una velocidad y fidelidad increíbles.
Dadas las limitaciones de las máquinas hechas por el hombre,
la biología sintética será un nuevo medio para diseñar no solo nuestra comida,
combustible y medioambiente,
sino también a nosotros mismos
para compensar nuestros defectos físicos
y asegurar nuestra supervivencia en el espacio.
Para dar un ejemplo de cómo
podemos usar la biología sintética para la exploración espacial,
volvamos al medioambiente marciano.
La composición del suelo marciano es similar
a la de cenizas volcánicas de Hawái,
con trazas de material orgánico.
Digamos, hipotéticamente,
que el suelo de Marte podría sustentar en realidad el crecimiento de plantas
sin necesidad de nutrientes derivados de la Tierra.
Quizás la primera pregunta que deberíamos hacer es
¿cómo podemos hacer las plantas tolerantes al frío?
Porque, en promedio, la temperatura en Marte
es de unos muy atractivos 60 grados bajo cero.
La siguiente pregunta es
¿cómo hacemos las plantas tolerantes a la sequía?
La mayor parte del agua que se forma tras una helada
se evapora antes de que pueda decir la palabra "evaporar".
Resulta que ya tenemos hecho este tipo de cosas.
Al tomar prestadas genes de peces para obtener proteínas anticongelantes
y genes de otras plantas como el arroz para desarrollar resistencia a la sequía
e insertarlas luego en las plantas que los necesitan,
acabamos por tener plantas que toleran la mayoría de las sequías y heladas.
Son conocidas en la Tierra como los transgénicos,
u organismos genéricamente modificados,
y confiamos en ellos para alimentar a toda la civilización humana.
La naturaleza hace este tipo de cosas también,
sin nuestra ayuda.
Nosotros hemos encontrado simplemente maneras más precisas de hacerlo.
Así que ¿por qué queremos cambiar la composición genética de las plantas
para el espacio?
Bueno, no hacerlo significaría usar la ingeniería
para un sinfín de hectáreas de tierra en todo un nuevo planeta
liberando billones de litros de gases atmosféricos
para luego construir una cúpula de cristal gigante para contenerlo todo.
Es una empresa de ingeniería poco realista
que puede convertirse rápidamente
en una misión de transporte de carga de alto costo.
Una de las mejores maneras de asegurarnos de tener
los suministros necesarios de alimento y aire,
es llevar con nosotros organismos que han sido diseñados
para adaptarse a entornos nuevos y difíciles.
o sea organismos manipulados para ayudarnos a terraformar un planeta
tanto a corto como a largo plazo.
Estos organismos pueden también ser diseñados
para crear medicinas o combustible.
Así que podemos usar la biología sintética
para llevar plantas de alta ingeniería con nosotros,
pero ¿qué otra cosa podemos hacer?
Bueno, he mencionado anteriormente que nosotros, como especie,
fuimos evolucionado de forma única para el planeta Tierra.
Este hecho no ha cambiado mucho en los últimos cinco minutos
mientras Uds. estaban sentados y yo estaba aquí de pie.
Así que si tuviéramos que mandar a cualquiera de nosotros a Marte
en este mismo momento,
con comida, agua, aire y un traje espacial
estaríamos propensos a experimentar problemas de salud muy desagradables
debido a la radiación ionizante que bombardea la superficie
de planetas como Marte que tienen poco o nada de atmósfera.
A menos que contemos con quedarnos bajo tierra
durante nuestra estancia en cada uno de estos nuevos planetas,
tenemos que encontrar mejores maneras de protegernos
sin necesidad de recurrir a llevar una armadura
que pese casi lo mismo que nuestro propio peso corporal,
o la necesidad de ocultarnos detrás de una pared de plomo.
Así que recurramos a la naturaleza en busca de inspiración.
Entre las formas de vida que existen aquí en la Tierra,
hay un subconjunto de organismos conocido como extremófilos,
o amantes de las condiciones de vida extremas,
si recuerdan la clase de biología.
Y entre estos organismos hay una bacteria llamada Deinococcus radiodurans,
capaz de soportar el frío, la deshidratación, el vacío, los ácidos
y, sobre todo, la radiación.
Aunque se conocen sus mecanismos de tolerancia a la radiación,
aún tenemos que adaptar sus genes a los mamíferos.
Eso no es nada fácil.
Hay muchas facetas de su tolerancia a la radiación,
y el proceso no es tan simple como transferir un solo gen.
Pero con un poco de ingenio humano
y un poco de tiempo,
creo que no es muy difícil hacerlo tampoco.
Incluso si tomamos prestado
solo una fracción de su capacidad para tolerar la radiación,
estaríamos infinitamente mejor de lo que ya estamos
que es disponer de la melanina de nuestra piel.
Con la ayuda de las herramientas de la biología sintética,
podemos aprovechar las propiedades de la Deinococcus radiodurans
para prosperar en lo que de lo contrario sería una dosis muy letal de radiación.
Con lo difícil que es vislumbrarlo,
el Homo sapiens, es decir, los seres humanos,
evolucionamos todos los días,
y todavía seguimos evolucionando.
Miles de años de evolución humana
no solo hicieron posible la existencia de seres humanos como los tibetanos,
que pueden vivir con poco oxígeno,
sino también argentinos, que pueden ingerir y metabolizar arsénico,
un elemento químico que puede matar a un humano.
Cada día, el cuerpo humano evoluciona debido a mutaciones accidentales
igual que permite que ciertos humanos sobrevivan en condiciones sombrías.
Pero, y esto es un gran pero, dicha evolución requiere dos cosas
que no siempre tenemos o podemos permitirnos:
la muerte y el tiempo.
En la lucha de nuestra especie
por encontrar nuestro lugar en el universo,
puede ser que no siempre tengamos el tiempo necesario
para desarrollar de manera natural las funciones adicionales necesarias
para la supervivencia en otros planetas.
Estamos viviendo en lo que E.O. Wilson denominó la edad de la elusión genética,
durante la cual remediamos nuestros defectos genéticos
como la fibrosis quística o la distrofia muscular
con suplementos externos temporales.
Pero con cada día que pasa,
nos acercamos a la edad de la evolución volitiva,
una edad en la que, como especie,
podremos decidir por nosotros mismos
nuestro propio destino genético.
Mejorar el cuerpo humano con nuevas habilidades
es más bien una cuestión de cómo y no de cuándo.
El uso de la biología sintética
para alterar la composición genética de cualquier organismo vivo,
especialmente la nuestra,
no está exenta de dilemas morales y éticos.
¿Alterarnos a nosotros mismos nos hace menos humanos?
Pero, de nuevo, ¿qué es la humanidad
sino polvo de estrellas dotado de consciencia?
¿Hacia dónde debería encaminarse el genio humano?
Sin duda, es una pérdida de tiempo reclinarse para solo maravillarse con él.
¿Cómo podemos usar nuestro conocimiento
para protegernos de los peligros externos
y luego protegernos de nosotros mismos?
Planteo estas preguntas no para crear miedo a la ciencia
sino para sacar a la luz las muchas posibilidades
que la ciencia nos ofrece y nos sigue ofreciendo.
Como seres humanos hay que reunirse para discutir y adoptar las soluciones
tanto con precaución cómo también con valor.
Marte es un destino,
pero no será el último.
Nuestra verdadera y última frontera es la línea que debemos cruzar
para decidir lo que podemos y debemos hacer
con la inteligencia de nuestra especie.
El espacio es un lugar frío, brutal e implacable.
Nuestro camino a las estrellas estará plagado de intentos
que nos llevarán a preguntas
no solo del tipo de quiénes somos sino también adónde vamos a ir.
Las respuestas consistirán
en nuestra elección de usar o abandonar la tecnología
que hemos creado a partir de la vida misma,
y nos definirán para el resto de nuestra existencia en este universo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)